before we start today's episode check
this out it's our brand new
what if 100 book it features the 100
most popular what-if scenarios
as suggested by you learn more and get
this special collector's piece
by clicking in the link in the
description below
would you sleep in this earthquake proof
bed
it senses when an earthquake is
happening and drops you
into a safe metal chamber
yeah we know how ridiculous this looks
but
desperate times call for desperate
measures
because we're about to experience the
most powerful
earthquake in history a magnitude
20. how much damage would it cause
[Music]
would it break our planet into pieces
and what could cause such a massive
earthquake this is what if
and here's what would happen if a
magnitude 20
earthquake hits
to understand just how big a magnitude
20 earthquake would be
let's take a look at the richter scale
the richter scale is a logarithmic scale
that
rates the amount of energy released by
an earthquake
what does logarithmic mean well in this
case
it means that the amount of energy
released increases
31.7 times between whole number values
on the scale
for example a 2.0 quake
is 32 times as energetic as
a 1.0 event and a 3.0 quake
is 1 000 times more powerful than a 1.0
event
the largest earthquake ever recorded
registered a magnitude of 9.5
and it caused about 5 billion dollars in
damage
it killed 655 people
and left 2 million people homeless
so how much worse would a magnitude 20
be
would we have to evacuate the planet
to properly prepare for an earthquake
this big
we need to understand what causes
earthquakes in general
earthquakes are vibrations that travel
through the crust of the earth
they can be caused by events like
volcanic eruptions and meteor impacts
but
the movement of tectonic plates is what
usually causes them
these plates which make up the earth's
crust
can slide against each other at a region
called the transform boundary
when the plates move in different
directions
they can cause a break in the earth's
crust called
a fault line this is where most
earthquakes take place
the plates create friction as they push
together tightly
and if there's enough friction they can
become locked together
and stop sliding but the forces of the
earth will continue to push
against them and increase the pent-up
energy and pressure
when the pressure builds up enough it
will overcome the friction
and result in an intense and sudden
shift
this causes the vibration we know as
an earthquake and the longer the fault
line
the more massive the earthquake
so how long of a fault line would be
required to produce a magnitude 20
earthquake
well let's put it this way to produce a
magnitude 10.5 earthquake
you'd need a fault line of about 80 000
kilometers
and given that the earth's circumference
is
only about 40 000 kilometers that would
be highly unlikely
with all that considered a magnitude 20
earthquake seems
pretty impossible so there's nothing to
worry about
oh right except for that
one way that a magnitude 20 earthquake
could occur would be due to
a massive asteroid impact an earthquake
this large
would last longer than any earthquake
we've ever experienced
you would feel the shaking for at least
five minutes
and aftershocks would go on for hours
tsunamis and volcanic eruptions would be
taking place
more earthquakes would likely be
triggered and the whole world would be
falling apart
literally for the power of this
earthquake to destroy the planet
it would need to overcome something
called the gravitational binding energy
which describes the minimum value a
spherical and uniform object needs
to keep together under the influence of
gravity
now we won't go into specific values
here because
we don't want to make things any more
complicated so believe it at this
we're screwed a magnitude
20 earthquake would produce more than
enough energy to
overcome the gravitational binding
energy and
destroy our planet but the good news is
that we would likely see the massive
asteroid coming
and would have time to prepare for
everything that comes with it
would it be enough time to get off the
planet before it explodes
well that's a story for another
what if
[Music]
you